I called Eduardo
alro and I am Spanish, I come from
Madrid and as a commission
myl
some of them wit some of them funny some
of them illogical and some of them even
r were also some tweets Which combined
all these elements in one and these were
the most interesting for  translators and
were
the we had to translate from the
poster and we immediately
understood the message, and it was also very
short, very
simple, the idea that there is a machinery
in Europe but it is a machinery that
is in each of the countries, if one of
the countries fails, they will fail.  I all think that it
is an idea that young people
and adolescents often have much
clearer ideas about things than adults
and it was very easy to
translate
with the young people of the Europe to
give them a possibility to take Part in
the Nobel
prony in oslo I It's hug hug not like
Win B To This is once In A
lifetime